let's let's get more offensive to the
feminists let's do it
we got the story this is from daily mail
women reveal how their appearances have
dramatically changed since they met
their partners
saying comfort eating birth control and
babies have completely altered their
bodies
this is this is in many ways the purpose
of marriage
young women and young men getting
together and having a contract to each
other
under god till death do us part because
they didn't
because back in the day it's a problem
if a dude continues continuously becomes
more valuable and more attractive and
the woman doesn't
and then you end up with a bunch of
angry women and you end up with a bunch
of
philandering men or womanizing men to
have structure they said okay we'll do
marriage well nowadays
divorce marriage is meaningless there
was a meme where it was like
it was a guy in his knee with a ring and
he says will you enter into a government
contract with me that you're allowed to
break at any time and if you do you get
half my stuff
and she says yes yes a million times yes
it's like if that's the
that's the mentality that we have this
today there's there's
there's no guarantee in marriage why
would anyone do it
back in the day if you tried to get
divorced the judge would be like i
sentence you to marriage counseling
like you can't you've got to figure it
out and you guys have a mutual
agreement with each other you've got a
family you're gonna raise it
and it made sense so today
i think this is a good example of why
there was marriage
you got images of these women which
gonna i mean these are posts
they show themselves being a size six
meeting my bf
and here's her two years later as a 12
to 14 due to contraception and eating
bad food the first few months of uh
after uh meeting him
so now she's you know getting overweight
here's one where she's like here's me
first
me my bf and now here's here's her now
to be fair this one she's actively
pregnant so i don't think that's
actually fair to criticize her here's
one where she's like here's how i look
i'm fat
there there are a ton of women
celebrities or otherwise who have kids
and then go work out and get fit get
back in shape because they're they're
trying to look good and there are a lot
of women that look really really good
as soon as they get married that's the
trope they let they let themselves go
that's why is it that in tv shows they
have that trope of
letting themself go so i'll say this
right
think about this you play a game right
and let's say you're playing level one
okay you're doing whatever you need to
do to make level two
at the last stage level 10 is a boss
right at the boss fight
you pull all the stops you upgrade your
weapons you finally use your potions
exactly exactly so you have the last
legendary weapon
you slay the the boss now you finish the
game you're not putting any more effort
into the game because you already won
the game
same thing with relationships with these
women they find a guy that they can lock
down and
take care of them and they put all the
effort into it at the beginning to get
get a guy yeah now that they got a guy
he's like okay if i leave
i get to have his stuff and i'll be good
so i can do whatever i feel like because
now he's under my
frame so i feel like marriage itself
church and store
um definitely has a place for women to
strive but for men it's a very
detrimental thing to do because you can
and i
i i won't say this right so women have
the advantage because they can leave any
time
and get what they want the guy if he
leaves he's going to lose
so i'm just saying in that situation
they have all the leverage
and just them just being there uh they
can win and do whatever they feel like
because
now they like i said before they get
everything and that's it i think the
prenuptial agreement should be automatic
and that you should have to file to do
away with it
the idea that there is no prenup going
into it and that everything you used to
own
is now half owned by that person because
of the signage is insane to me
here's the problem though prenups don't
always work no and if you do do a prenup
let's say they can say it was under
duress you know he forced me to do it
so they can also their way out my thing
is okay
why even get this pisses me off bro
because
it's kind of like i understand why women
leverage sex against many marriages
because they can
because think about it if you leave your
wife and you've been together for 10
years
alimony child support all these things
come into play
and you're stuck there so my thing is
these women can take advantage because
the law allows them to so how do you
avoid this don't get married
so yeah um here here's here's a really
interesting uh tidbit
we mentioned this in a previous segment
one of uh a large component
a large factor in divorces is the woman
making more money than the man
the man is no longer attractive when
he's not economically attractive because
like you guys mentioned what are women
are looking for lifestyle status
confidence
so if they're in a relationship and the
woman is making a bunch of money i have
the story for marketwatch they actually
actually say they frame in a very funny
way they say
this one thing in your marriage
increases the risk of divorce by 33
percent
and they're basically and they show the
image when the man is making more than
the woman
things are good when the woman is making
more than the man things are bad
basically when the man is no longer
attracted to woman she leaves
what about these guys that they're in a
relationship this woman says she beat
the game
she gets she lets herself go she has an
exercise she doesn't eat right anymore
now she's overweight and unattractive
it's it's it's it's wrong for the guy to
be like i'm not attracted to this
anymore you've
you've you know broken your agreement
with me here's the problem
um and i've said this on the show many
times and i'll say it i'm going to
probably trigger some feminists right
now but
the thing is this women want traditional
men but they don't want to necessarily
be traditional women
they want a guy that saw them makes more
money than them confident attractive etc
if someone breaks into the house he can
handle it and protect her
and be willing to die for her right but
she ain't going to make him a sandwich
oh you toxic misogynist make your own
sandwich
so they want to be modern women when it
suits them but they want to be
traditional when it suits them as well
and that's the problem that's why we
tell guys don't get married nowadays
don't put yourself in a situation where
the woman has all the leverage because
when she has the leverage bad things are
going to happen and we know it because
look at
80 of divorces are initiated by women so
you see what happens when women have
leverage
they leave and here's the other thing
like as a man you
have a burden of performance men don't
ask for much from women
women ask far more of men than men ask
of women so my thing is
something simple like bedroom fun will
keep you too friendly right
how many sexless marriages are there out
there or worse yeah i see on tick tock
a wife saying you're not going to get
any unless you take out the trash
uh you're not going to get any unless
you mow the lawn blah blah blah but if
someone breaks into the house
you're expected to protect this woman
with your life and she don't even want
to give you no bedroom fun
that's bs that's why we tell guys most
of the time unless you want to have kids
you shouldn't get married at all because
women
get in line when they know that you have
other women in line that's why we tell
guys to not date
exclusively it's a date not exclusively
you know so let's let's think about the
the the actual math of this of the
situation sure
it sounds like feminism has been the
greatest gift
to to um
feminism has actually reverted society
back to a more primitive state
yes yes yeah because of feminism i would
say it's the greatest
like i said high value men guys who are
confident successful wealthy
they can get any woman they want
whatever they want with no obligations
no commitment and better yet
half the time the women are are working
careers and doing in doing a bunch of
the work
so there was a meme where a feminist was
like or it was a meme where someone a
woman said
feminism is a trick you guys the men are
going to sit around playing video games
all day while they make us do all the
work
right but so it's a joke but what ends
up happening is
you look back at how things used to be
in the tribal sense
yep the the alpha male the high value
man would you know whatever woman he
wanted
all of them all of them and if you look
at how uh
in the animal kingdom you know typically
it's like the most dominant powerful
male like
you know takes all the women teen wives
roosters got like 12 ladies they take it
they fight each other they kill the
other one and they take their harem
so right now because of all this like
you mentioned
these guys go on on instagram and they
can just dm
50 women and get back five messages and
then one of them is a go
yep yep and that's what i've said it
before what feminism feminism has
actually done
is give given all the sexual leverage to
the highest tier men
inadvertently to the unbeknown to them
they've basically given all leverage to
the men that will never
actually commit to them and what happens
is the guys that are you know good
husbands
good potential long-term partners those
guys get left out in the dust
and the women don't come back to them
until you know maybe their youth is gone
or whatever it may be and then you end
up
with these marriages that don't end up
working out because the guy isn't
getting her best but he's still held to
a certain standard he has to provide
so there was a chart i think it might
have been leonardo dicaprio but if it's
not forgive me leo for best marching
your your honorable name
but it was like this guy dates women
and marries women and divorces them at
the exact like almost the exact same
ages
like you're dating at 24 and then like
oh yeah it's leo he doesn't date any
girl over 25
25 yeah like he dates and then and then
dumps him then dates and then yep
he like dates him smart man very smart
smart he's because here's the thing
let's be honest about it right
the women want him for his status and
his value right
right they want to be around uh you know
an a-list celebrity whatever
so he's like okay you want to share my
time with a high status man
i want the bet the best and the
brightest the problem is this when men
put women
on uh we want preferences this is what
we want in women it's considered
misogynistic and rude or discrimination
but when a woman has standards it's
considered preferences
it's completely okay for women to exert
their boundaries and what they want in
men
but it's not okay for men to do it men
are shamed for doing it think about what
we're talking about in this segment
a guy could lose his job and make less
money and now he's not economically
attractive anymore
and then you get a divorce but a man
like even criticizing the fact that
these women are overweight
they let themselves go and it's
considered misogynistic or or sexist or
female take it a step further society
actually encourages women
to leave their men we no longer provides
because they get the money 80
of divorces are initiated by women the
family courts destroy men they're
they're heavily gynocentric
gynocentric so what is is there any
benefit to really getting married in
today's day and age
i can't see many even social media you
see all the time girls leaving their men
for other men and
it's funny because when you're married
to a woman right guess what happens
let's say you lose your job like you
said earlier and you're no longer you
know i would say
you're no longer like attractive to her
she can go cheat and have fun on the
side
and then still thanks for checking out
this clip from the tim cast irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel youtube.com
tim cast irl monday through friday at
8pm where you can leave comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time